one of the things that's really
interesting about zuckerberg that i
noticed is like you know in his early
years like he was pretty alpha like he
was alpha as [ __ ] right like he
basically stole
a lot of the code for facebook from the
wiggles twins i don't think that's all
right i think i think it's weasley
unapologetic about it right he was like
you know screw this like i'm doing this
man any and he just like but he's on his
game man that's his hospital
he's quite he's quite dark wasn't he
really yeah if you watch that movie what
was it the social network he comes
across very sort of yeah machiavellian
sort of dark triad in that
yeah he's a weasel though he's
definitely not yeah yeah but he's not
alpha that's like back trait that's
backstabbing beta [ __ ] so so like one of
the things that that uh john and i were
talking about about a week ago um you
know we're just shooting the [ __ ] over a
quick call and i said to him you know
basically the opening i know he kind of
hopped in after we opened but i know he
knows what we're talking about here i'm
like can you name one billionaire that
is an alpha male that's unplugged from
you know society's lies and we couldn't
really come up with anything
what about you said like dan bilzerian
like you know but what's he worth a
couple hundred what about the capital
his name without people going he buys
his chicks
what about the late the late john mcafee
he was a billionaire wasn't he
yeah no uh virgin guy what's his name
branson
i don't think he was a billionaire but i
think he was quite up there but i would
say branson was when he was younger for
sure like if you
if you read branson's biography for sure
he was when he was younger maybe up
until about the age of 30 35 but i think
there's an argument too like when a lot
of these guys get married we know their
testosterone levels drop they get
hand-picked or cuck to some degree it's
like to what degree are you going to be
uh you know packed and like chopped down
a few notches so that's going to change
their personality vince mcmahon is a
good example okay so what about him
because he's worth a couple of billion
dollars right
he's a boss he's a billionaire so what's
what's the what's the thing we're saying
here like why are so many why are why
are billionaires like wealthy men
plugged in betas
like are we so we're talking about betas
or red pill and alpha what's the
difference here
well i mean i'll tell you what why don't
you just kind of loop no jumps yeah like
these build jumps like average
first-rate jumps you know for the most
part i'll tell you this outside of money
and chasing excellence one of the
feathers in my cap is i have red killed
a mate of mine who is worth
in the deck of millions
and
he is an insufferable douche
like to tell him to tell him anything
and i would i just when i met him i
didn't know he was and i don't really
care if somebody has money or not i just
like talked to him as a man
and i was just like listen dude you're a
[ __ ] dork and you're real creepy when
you do these certain things and i was
like this is why you're failing and i
was like you're good i was like you're a
boomer like he's not he's like in his
early 40s i'm like dude you're a boomer
like the way you think about girls do we
communicate with them the way you text i
was like you're i called him the rainbow
f-bomb quite frankly i was like dude
you're you're you're acting like a damn
rainbow f-bomb
and i was like girls not going to
respect this and they're not going to be
turned on by this like you saw about
this
um
you know you maybe saw this was on like
cnn or something like how to treat a
woman but this is not how it works and i
had to like
consciously beat this into his head over
a series of months till finally he got
fed up he got on tinder and he
like just like was just very direct with
his seduction
and he scored himself a really hot 19
year old
and i was just like you know yeah dude
because you've been a like a weird
creepy like beta boomer your whole life
and like yeah that works in your
corporate world where you know how it is
in corporate you got to be fake you got
to be backstabbing you got to be devious
you got to like pretend to be somebody
you're not the entire time like that
doesn't work with chicks like they're
going to sniff that out like within the
first date
but it's just so hard to tell these guys
anything and another thing is this too
i think like my just
what he interpreted as disrespect when i
met him i was just like no you're wrong
right because when you're a millionaire
when you're multi-millionaire people
know you have money people you know you
have power they bow down to you you get
you get surrounded by yes men so yes all
the time everything i think you buy this
girl flowers yeah man those great on
titanic you know i think i should uh i
think you know i think i should do this
i think you should do that
and and literally you you are there's a
chance
when you're talking to a guy and getting
dating advice for him he is blue pill
there's literally 99 chance
so you know that's that's what happens
with these guys and i think that's why
they get in a lot of trouble because
then they start like i think a perfect
example is this tech lead guy that like
weird chinese yeah i've actually talked
with that guy before but yeah
sorry i'm sorry about that yeah um he's
he's like an insufferable beta with a
power trip right i actually tried to get
him on my show because because he
mentioned some of my stuff in a couple
of his videos and people sent me the
videos
he's like no i don't he's all blind yeah
yeah oh for sure rollo but i can tell
that guy's a real twerp in real life i
can just tell by the way he acts and
it's like no wonder you got taken to the
cleaners with your woman right the more
of a [ __ ] you are the more your woman
is going to punish you when she breaks
up
and so that's why she fleeced him up and
down
he took his kid to japan man she she's
bailed like like here today and then
gone tomorrow man
but i mean like you can't have that
conversation you know with men when
you're when you're trying to offer them
some level of
protection
in their lives like hey you know like
there's some [ __ ] landmines out there
that you can step on and here's a road
map that you might want to look at so
you don't step on them oh no they lose
their [ __ ]
yeah it's it's hard it's hard to get
past that because again they're so
ingrained in their belief systems too
because some of the worst
yeah because because you know they've
been telling people you're wrong their
entire life that's why they're rich
right but
in this sense like it's a completely
different skill set just because you
like just because you can make millions
of dollars still doesn't mean those
principles are going to apply to female
nature one of the most complicated thing
you could do with your entire life
is to figure out women and [ __ ] have
a successful womanizer life and then i
think personally like that's why a lot
of these guys uh
i think that's why a lot of these guys
just get so rich because honestly
speaking do you think steve jobs would
have been as productive elon musk would
have been as productive if he was like
me he just always had four girls on the
phone ready to roll just like i pick you
up hey come baby hey come come come elon
musk is a really good example of that
too because if you look at the women
that have been in his life for as long
as like he's with this is he still with
grimes right now i think his father
still is yeah
look at his dating history or his like
women history it's like wow it's [ __ ]
atrocious man yeah and the reason mary
is like three times like twice the same
woman wasn't he with amber heard for a
while too he was yeah yeah
that went out and i thought about
dodging that video right a video on uh
elon musk because i think it was neil
strauss did an interview him and i kind
of broke down the interview i remember
that and a lot of people lost his phone
like how dare you talk about elon musk
that way he's my hero and it's like whoa
hold on a second dude like i'm just like
holding up a mirror and just reflecting
back some facts here right like these
are all factual things that happen like
he was curled up in a ball during the
interview basically crying because he
couldn't keep it together because he
like he didn't understand females
world-class at building [ __ ] electric
cars raising money
you know rocket ships into space but
with women and his personal life i mean
like look at look at who he's invited
into his personal life a woman named
grimes yeah have you guys like seen the
backstory with grimes yes
yes yes well another good example is
also if you look at like a guy like
anthony bourdain for example
when he ended up committing suicide and
i believe it was back in 2018.
um i did uh i did a series of shows with
uh pat campbell back then we were
talking about that and when i brought up
anthony bourdain and i said he was very
blue pill
when it came to women right people just
ran me up the flagpole you don't know
who he is you don't know he's got more
money than you're professionally jealous
and he's like this con i'm not attacking
the dude yeah yeah obviously he's done
something very constructive with his
life what was this anthony bourdain
yeah he's not anything anymore because
he had because of the decisions and
because of this he's what i call the
terminal beta right he was so invested
in that hope and that romantic ideal and
that that soul mate myth that you know
he went like all of his friends would
say the same thing they just did a a
documentary about him not too long ago
and his friends would say the same thing
that he wears his heart on his sleeve
right he he really wanted to have like
the love of his life and of course when
you have that kind of money and when you
have that kind of status when you have
that kind of fame and everything else
that came with anthony bourdain i don't
think he was a billionaire but he's
certainly a millionaire um
yeah you become a target because women
sniff that out they go wow this is a guy
who's who's stacked with money he's he's
got some fame he's got some status
people want him he's you know he's he's
a hot item he's a big fish
he makes a really good mark for women
who understand what he represents and
those women are exactly the kind of
women that he ought to be
you know
steering clerics yeah avoiding but
because he is so locked into that blue
pill romantic ideal
he puts himself out there and he becomes
very vulnerable to the point where a
girl like asia argento satanist
asia arjuna witch whatever witchcraft to
asia argento
was the catalyst for him hanging himself
because she was seen you know by the
paparazzi in italy with her 29 year old
boy toy because she presumed that he was
adult enough to handle a paulie
relationship or an open relationship
apparently he wasn't and that was the f
he when when rose mcgowan by the way
who's like been in the news recently
because she's now the conservative
little sweetheart i always point this
out i say how's asia argento doing rose
because she was came jumped right to her
defense when that happened and i'm like
where is that where's that question
where where people are talking about
that now nobody is
you